i sincerely believe that if you go ahead
and try something new
or try to upscale try to kick it up a
notch on your current position
experience is is your best friend so i'm
miguel
and um i'm a product owner currently and
working for a thermofisher scientific
and with simple or not one of my
colleagues recommended me hey
you should go ahead and try to to be a
certified and simple learner is a good
tool to do that
um you have the option to go online the
course is really
complete it should definitely help you
out i went ahead and i
subscribed to the course via simple
learn uh the pmi acp
the album was a really good experience i
was something i really enjoyed is that
not using the content and you have like
a scheduled plan you can program
yourself like to to spend a certain
amount of time
a week to go and progress through the
course
but you can you can keep the information
for a lifetime and
that's really helpful for me and with
that i
was able to study at my own pace and
i was able to find success in my first
goal and my first
exam take i was able to pass it but
since i've taken my pmi
certification course and certification
i've seen a lot of differences like
before and after
uh one example that i can come up with
is like
other people not using inside the
company from outside the company try to
feel more about what you say on our
teams we we have
uh we have requirements that come
directly from different stakeholders
and different markets too even though
it's the same product different
customers have different implementations
of that product
so the requirements do change and we
have a complex environment where we need
to adopt ourselves to have
the to deliver the most value possible
so uh following yeah though really helps
on that
an advice that i can give to people
trying to build their analytical skills
and
basically upskill their their current uh
statuses
just learn be open uh always be curious
and don't be afraid to fail